it's so hard to keep it straight cuz I
have so many things I want to say first
of all when you met your husband who is
the funniest coolest most reverent
genius on the
planet nice
um what was meeting him like um and it's
like I've hung out with you but I've
never really asked you that question I
feel like we kind of bonded over our
humor and it's definitely kept us 22
years afloat with yeah and I feel like
we
met I want to say early on in La yeah
cuz I went on like a double date with
you and Sasha we went on a double date
and I was so excited I was so excited
for you guys and then you broke up an
hour later I know I know but like
Beyond you know having worked with so
many comedians because that was always
the genre I wanted you know to be in so
funny you are the funniest coming from
you I cannot you are the
funniest so funny love you I mean I
would love you to do a movie with my
husband that would be really funny I
would give anything to do a movie with
your husband you have and you like the
three of us please that would be so fun
and Adam Sandow because it just would
make sense maybe that's the double date
in the movie me and Sandler you and
Sasha and then it seems like everybody
yes okay that's the premise I feel like
we could get actually get this made okay
so my kid's dad the other day um he goes
by the way the whole Wedding Crashers
thing and I go what what do you mean
Wedding Crashers and he goes well I I
saw saw you on like Tik Tok or Instagram
like sending out a shout out to Adam
Sandler and I go do you mean The Wedding
Singer and he goes yes yes I'm sorry I
met The Wedding Singer I had such a
moment where I was like I wish I was in
Wedding Crasher so badly and you made
your career in that film by doing one of
the strongest most iconic female comedic
performances ever thank you thank you so
ni thank you but I I would say that um
that was one of the rare times and you
know this that there was a funny role
for a woman and not a wife of a funny
character that's a man or a girlfriend
or a love interest that's the straight
man that was the time where my character
got to deliver the jokes and Vince fa's
character had to be you know the
straight man and that dance was was
given to me I got a turn and it was just
so magical and fun but you have a very
dramatic role something of very
different tone wolf like me like this is
such an amazing story and part and thank
in season one you know we're in
discovery mode and there's Josh Gad and
I love Josh Gad I love Josh Gad oh my
God love him so we're actually going to
have a little trivia um where is
Megan Hi
Megan here's your question what toy did
Isa love growing up was it a a password
journal b a ventriloquist doll or c a
jewelry making
kit H don't answer we're going to go to
the quick break and come back think
about it we'll be right back